[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je dis 14 décembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition d'actualité locale
elle est en place à la gare sncf de
saint quentin en yvelines la vélostation
a été inauguré aujourd'hui
ce nouveau service permet de pouvoir
stationner louer et même faire réparer
votre vélo
les précisions à suivre redonner le
sourire aux enfants malades pour égayer
leur quotidien un défi que se fixent
l'association rire 78 rires pour guérir
c'est le long de 7 actions qu'elle mène
dans les établissements médicaux comme
hier à l'hôpital andré-mignot au chesnay
avec un spectacle pour noël et puis
c'est la période des marchés noël en ce
moment et qu en course est un marché
solidaire qui se tient ce samedi 16
décembre proposé par le comité de
jumelage de guyancourt et nous recevrons
son président dans ce journal george vi
tlic
et donc qui organise ce rendez vous le
monde agricole en colère les syndicats
de la fnsea et des jeunes agriculteurs
appellent à une grande mobilisation ce
mardi 19 décembre à paris
objectif interpeller le président de la
république emmanuel macron et le
gouvernement sur le sentiment
d'exclusion ressentie par le secteur et
notamment l'engagement de la france
auprès de l'union européenne dans des
traités de libre-échange avec le canada
l'amérique latine ou encore le japon est
d accord qui permettrait à terme par
exemple de voir arriver en europe 70
mille tonnes de viande bovine
supplémentaires sans droits de douane un
risque pour le président des jeunes
agriculteurs d'ile-de-france écouter le
risque c'est que aujourd'hui on a étudié
hier qu'ils sont quand même en
difficulté le fait d'importer
massivement des produits des denrées
alimentaires de l'international c'est
pas nouveau mais là ça va être encore
être encore avec un effet de volume plus
important
bien évidemment la par le biais de cette
action syndicale des 19 mettre en avant
et communiquer auprès du consommateur
parce que le consommateur n entendra en
attente d'un produit
alimentaires de qualité et en gros le
gouvernement nous fait part de bell
volonté avec les états généraux de
l'alimentation mais en complément en
parallèle on va mettre en place et
traités là qu'ils vont faire venir des
produits alimentaires qui ne
respecteront en aucun cas nos cahiers
des charges qu'on a nous français donc
en fait on se sent désabusés de cette
situation parce que on se moque du
consommateur et en plus on fait croire
qu'on va faire le plein de belles choses
en france mais par contre on va quand
même malgré tout à porter massivement
plein de produits qui restent encore
esponde pas la mobilisation donc à
l'appel de la fnsea et des jeunes
agriculteurs c'est à suivre ce mardi 19
décembre à paris elle était très
attendue sur le territoire annoncé
depuis plusieurs mois la vélostation a
ouvert ses portes ce matin en gare de
saint quentin en yvelines
trois services ils sont proposés un
stationnement sécurisé un service de
location de vélos ainsi qu'un atelier de
réparation et de maintenance les détails
dorés lyons des vélos qui attendent
leurs futurs compagnons de route
voici la vélostation de saint quentin en
yvelines après sept ans d'attenté les
saint quentinois bénéficie désormais
d'un espace pour leur deux roues deux
cent trente emplacements sécurisés
vous avez un lecteur de badge à
l'extérieur on passe le pass navigo et
donc la personne l'utilisateur rentre
son vélo et le stationnent sur les sur
les
est ce parce qu'ils sont prévus à cet
endroit autre service proposé par la
vélostation la location de vélos il y en
a cent soixante dix ans tout compter 3
euros la journée pour la location d'un
vélo standard 15 euros par jour pour un
vélo à assistance électrique
enfin un service de maintenance propose
de s'occuper de votre deux roues la
personne prend rendez vous nous
l'accueillons à l'atelier et nous
entretenons réparons le vélo su voir un
forfait près établi pièces et main
d'oeuvre pour des prestations qui vont
de la crevaison
la révision générale du vélo avec ses
400 km d'aménagements cyclables
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'inscrit dans
une démarche de mobilité durable
objectif avec cette vélostation
encourager les usagers de la gare à
utiliser ces transports propres
la part modale d'utilisateurs est encore
relativement peu élevé 2 % mais donc
avec ce ces nouvelles facilités a déçu
on espère d'affaires passer de 4 à 5%
donc au moins la doubler assez
prochainement
enfin sachez que se déplaçait à vélo est
bon pour l'environnement mais aussi bon
sur la santé une pratique quotidienne
permettrait d'allonger de cinq ans son
espérance de vie
elle intègre l'équipe nationale du parti
elle l'est républicain la sénatrice
salaires des yvelines sophie primas été
nommé par le nouveau président laurent
wauquiez pour rappel il a été élu
dimanche dernier à la tête de la
formation politique de droite sophie
primas qui a un rôle directement en lien
avec sa fonction de sénatrice
l illinois et secrétaire générale
adjointe en charge des relations avec
les parlementaires et des sourires et du
rire nous avons l'habitude de les voir
sur les visages des enfants ils se
feront pourtant plus rares qu'en ce ces
enfants sont malades est habitué à
l'hôpital pour tenter d'égayer à leur
quotidien l'association à rire 60,18
propose des spectacles et à l'hôpital
andré mignot du chesnay c'était déjà
noël
un reportage de nicolas kirillovitch
éclats avant quand mme berg avec un
spectacle et quelques sourires c'est fou
ce que l'on peut faire pour des enfants
à l'hôpital
à quelques jours de noël en guise de
cadeau avant l'heure une centaine
d'entre eux a pu profiter d'une
animation à l'hôpital du chesnay
histoire de délaisser soucis et problème
l'espace de quelques instants
c'est pour les petits sortir du
quotidien médical vraiment en fait
côté affectif plutôt que côté maladie
l'objectif c'est de rendre qui peut la
vie plus sereine meilleur à tous ces
gens qui ont eu un pépin un costume et
pour faire sourire ses enfants à
l'hôpital parce qu'à la cie auteur
compositeur habitué des performances
pour les plus jeunes propose un
spectacle tout en musique et en chansons
eh ben je savais qu'on peut faire des
gares et des petits suisses
c'est aussi un spectacle
comme un autre mais parfois on est pris
par surprise par l'émotion pas ce qui va
se dérouler un événement inattendu
différents proposés par l'association
rire 78 depuis dix ans l'opération rire
pour guérir est aussi un temps pour le
corps médical
un temps qui permet de créer un lien
différent et rassurant pour les enfants
de voir que les soignants peuvent
proposer un spectacle
e
de proposer eux
enfin de voir les soignants sourire et
rire et nous aussi de veut connaître les
parents et de voir les enfants sourire
et rire ça nous fait ça fait du bien à
tout le monde tous les ans rires 78
propose une dizaine de spectacles dans
les hôpitaux yvelinois des parenthèse
heureuse pour tenter de vaincre la
maladie santé toujours et un chercheur
yvelinois de l'inra auréolé joël doré
vient d'être désigné lauréat du prix
marcel dassault 2017 pour la recherche
sur les maladies rares
récompensée pour son projet sur le lien
entre la flore intestinale et trouble du
spectre de l'autisme sujet de nicolas
kirilow vite et patrick jacques de
dixmude notre intestin
ce deuxième cerveau ou vie des dizaines
de milliers de milliards de micro
organismes
aurait-il un lien avec certaines
maladies mentales
s'il est difficile d'arrêter aujourd'hui
une réponse la recherche avance joël
doré a reçu le prix marcel dassault 2017
pour son projet sur le microbiote
intestinal
chez les personnes avec trouble du
spectre de l'autisme
l'objet du projet est de mieux
documenter mieux caractériser la
relation entre le patient et son micro
butt
dans le contexte de des troubles du
spectre de l'autisme avec notamment un
accent mis sur 7
relation altéré qui fait que plus de la
moitié des patients ont des symptômes
gastro-intestinaux pour tenter de
comprendre les relations entre les
bactéries présentes dans l'intestin et
les troubles de l'autisme deux cent
cinquante mille euros seront mises à
disposition du projet de joël doré une
manne financière qui pourrait à terme
améliorer la qualité de vie des patients
on met en oeuvre des outils qui sont les
plus performants aujourd'hui pour la
caractérisation du microbiote intestinal
et puis on va aussi inclure des patients
donc 150 patients autiste asperger 50
individus contrôle qu'on va caractériser
de façon exhaustive à la fois au plan
clinique pour les patients mais aussi au
plan de la physiologie de la nutrition
du microbiote intestinal bien sûr avec
des outils qui sont performants mais
également cher les troubles de l'autisme
touche aujourd'hui soixante mille
personnes en france
un chiffre qui ne cesse d'augmenter
alors qu'il n'existe pour le moment
aucun traitement curatif vivre
sereinement sa grossesse et connaître
les démarches à suivre pour faciliter
les choses aux futures mamans et aux
futurs papas à la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des yvelines propose
des ateliers
le programme se nomme mon parcours
maternité explications avec aurélie
ronge et mélanie poquet leurs ventes
repoussent leurs questions aussi ces
femmes participent à mon parcours
maternité un dispositif de la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines il s'adresse surtout aux femmes
enceintes de trois à six mois de
grossesse
c'est un atelier qui est destiné à leur
expliquer les démarches administratives
qui sont nombreuses lorsqu'on attend un
premier enfant qui sont souvent aussi
méconnu donc on leur explique en détail
ce que ça recouvre d'être enceinte et
d'être aussi assurer des yvelines
on explique les modes de relation
attendu à la fois par la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie mais également par
les autres organismes institutionnels
quels sont les droits au congé maternité
et paternité les examens obligatoires
tout au long de la grossesse ce premier
atelier est un temps d'échangé auquel
sont conviés les jeunes mamans mais pas
seulement
le congé paternité que alors on en avait
j'en avais déjà entendu parler mais sans
savoir exactement comment il était
comment ils étaient formulées sur les
indemnités également au niveau du congé
maternité puisque congé maternité ses
démons qu'on entend tous les jours mais
on sait pas derrière ce que ça ce que
cela représente
intéressée pourra voir les nouveautés en
fait pour les femmes enceintes et après
la naissance pour le bébé et tout
qu'est-ce que je bénéfices de l'année
c'est l'assurance maladie les frais et
tout c'est bien c'est bien organisé
ça c'est convivial personnes sont assez
à l'écouté on peut poser nos questions
des questions qu'on peut pas forcément
posé sur le site donc c'est vraiment je
pense que c'est vraiment une bonne idée
pour pour tout le monde
autant pour les mamans que pour les
futurs papas le prochain atelier portera
lui sur la prévention santé
un coach sportif informera sur le
sommeil ou encore le mal de dos il m'a
rejoint sur ce plateau c'est georges
viêt lic bonsoir mon choix est le
président du comité de jumelage de
guyancourt on le disait tout à l'heure
dans les titres votre association
organise demain un marché solidaire au
profit de la ville de com et c'est au
bénin donc c'est ce samedi à 16 décembre
de 10 heures à 17 heures à la maison de
quartier à théodore monod on va en
parler dans un instant de ce marché déjà
peu présentes ont peut-être cette ville
de com est une ville donc du bénin un
grand pôle commercial du bénin 60000
habitants à une grande ville de par son
marché que pouvez-vous nous dire sur
colline pour qu'on la connaisse mieux
cette ville comme est une ville qui est
à proximité est tout à fait au sud du
bénin à proximité de l'océan et à
proximité de la grande ville de la
capitale de cotonou comme et est une
commune qui est montrée comme exemplaire
pour sa vie sociale est d'accord et le
côté calme de 2,2
de l'avis des habitants par rapport à
tout au moins 2 du bénin et peut-être
même d'une grande zone africaine donc
fait une tranquille même si il y à 60000
habitants c'est pas négligeable
ça fait combien de temps que lui en
cours et comme et son jumelage avec
comme et a été signé officiellement en
2004 donc ça fait 13 ans ça fait 13 ans
que vous êtes
cette fois on calcule mais du coup le
jumelage ça se fait comment commandes
bien comment ce on commet une ville de
ville de vienne jumelées finalement c
est ce que c'est un processus long que
voilà comment sont faits les contacts il
ya des contacts sont établis à la base
comment comment se fait ce fonds ces
contacts donc le le conseil municipal a
décidé à décider ou émis le souhait qui
de se jumeler avec une ville africaine
d'accord et ça c'est ce souhait a été
exprimé dans les années 90 est à une
année près je crois ne pas me tromper
on y reviendra premiers contacts ont été
pris avec des noms des délégations de
guyancourt sont allés en afrique là
l'orienter deux pays ils ont visité
je crois que c'était en l'an 2000
visiter comme et visiter le bénin est
aussi visiter un deuxième pays je fais
peut-être une erreur je passais le togo
très bien
le choix s'est porté sur le bénin et
dans la ville de comè ils ont trouvé des
gens intéressants et puis des contacts
ont été pris et repris dès les visites
ont été faites et en 2004 il y a eu la
grande décision l'accord bilatéral de
signature d'un accord de coopération et
d'échangés entre les deux qu'on a
appelée jumelage se c'était la troisième
ville à jumeler finalement eu lieu en
cours on dira un mot sur les deux autres
villes mais qui sont deux autres villes
sur en or à l'européenne guen je crois
d'ailleurs alors qu'ils aient une rue a
commis et qui s'appelle la rude lui en
cours comme à guyancourt il ya la rue
comme est parmi les grands travaux qui
ont été réalisés avec l'exemplarité de
nos de nos organisations
là ils ont appelé qu'ils ont fait
l'adressage gerber rue c'est à dire ils
ont donné des noms aux rues d'accord
donc il ya la rue de guyancourt ya aussi
la rue des sangliers
puisque quand il y a des d
des groupes de délégation béninoise qui
viennent à guyancourt qui sont logés à
l'ermitage et la rue dollard mais c'est
la rue des sangliers d'accord donc ils
ont retenu cette rue puisque c'est leur
maison en fait ici à guyancourt
alors vous l'avez dit créé leur jumelage
en 2004 qui remonte il ya treize ans
maintenant une fois que le jumelage est
fait entre deux villes votre votre
association le comité de jumelage
finalement quel rôle at il quelque l
échange lui met en place avec avec cette
villa alors le comité de jumelage a
commencé à avoir des créer des échanges
les premières choses qui ont été faites
c'était d'envoyer des conteneurs c'est à
dire le comité de jumelage de guyancourt
faisait les appels auprès de tous ses
adhérents pour et et même ailleurs pour
auprès des autres associations pour
rassembler des objets qui pourraient
être utiles donc des livres des du
matériel médical des médicaments
quantités demandées spécialement du
matériel de bureau comme de bureaux
informatique ou autre et on rassemblait
tout cela et on mettait en caisse et
bien rangé avec des noms des
destinataires et de la prise en charge
de l'envoi des contenaires été prise par
la commune
parce que le comité de jumelage n'a pas
la la la capacité financière de pouvoir
le faire à côté donc humanitaires telles
sont les grandes actions qui ont été
menées là depuis 2006 ces échanges ces
envois de containers on a vite arrêté
parce qu'on s'est aperçu que ça ne
suivait pas comme il fallait donc ça
marchait mal et il la commune aussi avec
il ya des choses qui fonctionnait pas
donc ils ont créé on a comment il
s'appelle une
un corps des coordinations de local de
la coopération décentralisée donc avec
des personnes responsables rémunérés par
la france oui je vois une pourcentage
par la commune de guyancourt et l'autre
pourcentage par le département ou par
l'île de france je ne sais pas trop où
exactement
et cette personne a la charge de
contrôler et de vérifier que tout se
passe bien là bas quand on envoie des
choses qui petit à petit on a arrêté
complètement parce que les ce qu'on
envoyait n'était pas forcément toujours
adapter le meilleur exemple c'était les
stylos bille pour les écoles les styles
obéit restait parfois presque une année
est distribuée et quand elles étaient
distribués cet essai qu'ils écrivaient
plus d'accord donc les livres scolaires
s'étaient pas non plus et donc on a
arrêté et les actions qu'on a fait par
la suite ce sont des actions dead
par exemple il y avait des relations qui
existaient entre l'école charlemagne de
guillon coin et l'école de dôi à commet
et les enfants pour aller à l'école et
devait emprunter
l'école est quasiment sur une île où une
presqu'île il ya un grand lac ils
étaient obligés de prendre le bateau la
pirogue pour aller à l'école
il devait payer comme on prend le bus
chez nous assure donc ce qu'on a
l'idée émise par l'école charlemagne de
l'époque c'était de l'heure de faire le
nécessaire pour qu'ils aient leur propre
pirogue donc ils ont fait des
réalisations ils ont vendu des objets
ils ont eu des sous ils ont envoyé
l'argent est là bas ils ont eu des plus
la pirogue de l'école et le comité de
jumelage à débat nous on puisque l'école
a fait ça nous a fait pareil il ya eu
deux pirogues
ça a été le changement doit être mis en
place si l'on fait la mairie la mairie
qui a été construite là bas la mairie de
guyancourt et des actions avec la mairie
ça c'est un échange de coopération et et
d'entre elles ce sont des ya des choses
qui se passent avec des des budgets qui
me dépasse complètement nous donc la
réalisation d'un
[Musique]
d'action mais on va venir sur le marché
solidaire justement ce qu'il nous reste
déjà une minute dans cet entretien vous
êtes venus avec des articles qu'on
pourra trouver sur ce marché solidaire
je rappelle il se déroule ce samedi à la
maison de quartier théodore monod 10h à
17h et donc il y aura de l'artisanat
africain revenir de l'artisanat africain
lancé cette année l'action qu'on amenait
on a fait un marché solidaire au mois de
mars pour avoir de l'argent et on a
rassemblé 800 euros et on avait déjà une
cagnotte de 1 100 euros ce qui fait
qu'on avait 1600 euros de disponible
pratiquement et on était sur un micro
projets qui nous avait proposé de
plantation de 500 arbres pour faire la
com et verte
donc on a envoyé 1500 euros pour cette
réalisation
c'est quelque chose d'énorme pour nous
et on a pu le faire et par le passé on
faisait sur la foire à la brocante on
vendait les objets tout ce qu'on pouvait
on arrivait bon an mal an rassemblé 2 ou
300 euros
là on a fait quelque chose de formidable
quoi et on s'est dit on va recommencer
on veut aller on veut des microprojets
et on y va de l'avant c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a ce marché solidaire
qui s'ouvre concret samedi là après
demain et m'a fait venir des
des l'artisanat de comè par les
délégations qui bouge donc dans les
valises
voilà quelques exemples voilà ce ces
zones des murs je suis désolé on arrive
déjà la fin de cet entretien mais en
tout cas on a retenu même compris
l'esprit les bijoux
voilà merci georges didier flic d'avoir
été avec nous désolé pourront varier
déjà afin de san luis en iran tout cas
vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site internet du
comité de jumelage de guyancourt qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et donc ce
marché c'est donc ce samedi à guyancourt
vous le savez donc c'est un moment la
période des marchés noël et c'est une
première c'est une première pour les
entrepreneurs de créer active à
l'association organisait aujourd'hui son
marché installé à la pépinière promo
paul à montigny le bretonneux les
visiteurs ont pu découvrir des produits
gourmands en créations textiles et
aromathérapie tour d'horizon avec
camille lambert gagner en créativité
retrouver l'équilibré ou instant
cocooning pour chaque humeur son parfum
c'est en tout cas ce que geneviève
souhaite faire découvrir des soins à
base d'huiles essentielles
on utilise donc l'aromathérapie et
l'olfactothérapie puisque
ce que l'on va faire et on va pulvériser
donc dans les mains on va frotter pour
pour faire évaporer l'alcool et ensuite
on va respirer l'odeur donc qui va
amener des nutriments au niveau 2 du
corps des produits présentés lors du
marché de noël de l'association
créactive les visiteurs avaient le choix
entre différents stands épicerie fine
photographie et accessoires textiles
sabine a rejoint l'association il y a 6
mois c'est sa première vente
c'est l'opportunité de se faire
connaître et puis aussi de tisser des
liens de se former de le réseau très
important dans nos métiers donc ce n'est
pas à négliger
c'est vrai quand on travaille en
indépendance qu on est souvent seul et
que ce moteur personnel on a quelquefois
du mal à le prouver donc là on se
soutient les unes des autres
entreprendre au féminin la devise de
l'association saint-quentinoise elle
compte plus de 130 membres
une dizaine d'entre elles ont joué les
mères noël lors de ce marché
ce marché de noël là est en préparation
celui de la commune de maurepas qui est
débute demain c'est jusqu'à dimanche en
centre-ville
l installation à des chalets se
faisaient est aujourd'hui comme vous
pouvez le voir sur ces images grands
classiques comme chaque année
l'installation se faisait ce soir c'est
la patinoire qui est place jacques
riboud une animation est gratuite pour
tous et pour le programme complet de ce
marché noël vous pouvez vous rendre sur
le site internet de la ville de maurepas
en sport le rugby club de versailles
reconnu pour son travail de formation
alors qu'elle vient de se voir
renouveller son label école de rugby
l association a reçu hier mercredi un
invité d'honneur thierry murie vice
président de la fédération française de
rugby a rendu à visite aux versaillais
au programme présentation du club
également en visite
c'était installations et présence lors
des entraînements des équipes jeunes
thierry murie qui a confié au micro de
tv 78 les raisons de sa venue
c'était effectivement très important de
venir voir cette magnifique école de
rugby
ces magnifiques installations parce que
c'est des installations qui sont
superbes et c'est une vraie valorisation
de ce club sur le travail qui a été
effectué pour la formation des jeunes et
c'est aujourd'hui que la fédération
recherche c'est de les valoriser un
moment la fédération doit se déplacer
dans ces clubs venir voir les clubs
formateurs le travail qu'ils font au
quotidien surtout une mercredi comme
aujourd'hui c'est le jour des enfants et
il y en a beaucoup d'arrières donc
effectivement ce dont on se doit d'aller
sur le terrain les rencontrais rencontre
à leur président les écouter savoir
leurs besoins aussi pour la formation on
est là pour ça mais pour refermer ce
journal ce week end à montigny le
bretonneux on entendra à des notes
baroque
les élèves du conservatoire de la ville
seront en concert à la salle jacques
brel
avant de alice et la scène au flûtiste
françois lazarevitch une représentant
une représentation pardon à qui termine
la semaine baroque du pôle musique et
théâtre
il était en master class sujet de
nicolas landry et mélanie poquet
les plaisirs de télé man l'un des
compositeurs allemands du style baroque
une époque au coeur d'une semaine dédiée
au conservatoire de musique de montigny
le bretonneux
c'est une des périodes qu'on enseigne
aux élèves période baroque c'est la
période de l'expression
des passions des mouvements de l'âme et
7 notamment ce qu'on demande souvent aux
élèves c'est d'interpréter des choses et
cette période là est tout à fait propice
à l'expression artistique
une découverte avec deux moments phares
des master class dirigée par françois
lazarevitch ce feu this tmusée piste et
le directeur des musiciens de
saint-julien sur une belle chose
d'enseignés c'est quelque chose qui me
qui personnellement me passionne parce
que c'est une façon de continuer
toujours à se remettre en question et à
sermonner on est tous en chemin réalité
alors on a certains ont un peu d'avancé
puis d'autres sont un peu plus débutant
dans le chemin mais enfin voila c'est
nous c'est une chaîne on dépasse le côté
un peu scolaire qu'on peut avoir parfois
quand on est avec sa prof habituel et on
a vraiment des cadets des conseils de
musicalité d'interprétation on sent que
ça va être plus joli à faire du coup on
prend confiance en soi et sera mieux
tendance que c'est ce que je ressens une
semaine de travail récompensé par un
concert le temps d'une soirée la salle
jacques brel sera pour eux
[Musique]
et
voilà sur ces quelques notes de musique
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal demain
vendredi vous avez rendez vous avec le
7-8 l'hebdo présenté par nicolas kirilow
vide ce nom se retrouvent lundi pour une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]